ただいまー肇社長ですというわけで4日元東京に言いました
生で結構久しぶりに東京に行って4日がも東京にいたんですけどそんなに何が久しぶり
だったんであまり嫌な気持ちにはならず
結構楽しかったです東京最高
とまでありませんでした自分静岡に帰ってきたんですけれどもそれをしてやっぱり東京
行くとバタついちゃってちょっとどうだか撮れなかったんですけども
今ちょっと僕のチャンネルを見るとチャンネル登録者数が590万人になっておりまし
たありがとうございます
やっぱりねもうすぐもうすぐついに600万人になってしまうという理由で
600万人記念質問コーナーしようと思いますでこさしぶりですね久しぶりに質問
コーナーをやりますでこの動画のコメント欄
この動画のコメント欄にコメントを書いてください質問でもいい質問コーナーと言って
質問コーナーじゃないんで
僕に言いたいことを言って欲しい方モンクリクエスト一言なんでもいいのであのなんか
こう言ってください
レオ質問コーナーの動画に使わせていただきましたの面白いのも使うかもしれないし
しょうもないのも使うかもしれないして真面目な質問を使うかもしれないし誹謗中傷は
やめていただきたいところでありますまあ何でもいつも好きなことを書いていただくと
何か僕がこう
てを手伝ったらどんどん採用しようと思いますのでみなさんぜひこのコメントに書いて
ください
て s 3 t なんですけども
ます
ちょっと呼べないですよね今回国は締め切りが読めないんですよ一応
イメージとしては600万人入ったタイミングでだと思います
質問コーナーなんであの5公開かわかんないんでちょっと収益にもいつかなんとなく
わからないんであのそれちょっと今回アバウトなんですけども栄転な母600番人気
そうだなぁまぁどれだけかかるかわかんないんですよねこっから伸びないという可能性
も
いますかそしたらもう僕は一生 a 人質問コーナーが出来だけだってしまいます
600万人に行くでも速ければ速いほど質問コーナーが早くなりますので皆さん是非
チャンネル登録の方もよろしくお願いしますねそこらへんにポチッと押せばできると
思うんでさぁコメント第6
今コメントを入れください
ああああああああ
あったとの距離ふと疲れレスはまあいろんな案系も含めと動画たくさん撮ってきたんで
まあいろいろね公開できればいいなと思っております
お楽しみに
[音楽]
はいみなさんコメント書けますでしょうかチャンネル登録数600万人たした日本人は
今のとこ
聞いてないとお伺いしておりますのでいけたらいっすでもう数字がでかすぎてさあもう
わけわかんないですよね
600万っても800万人間にふさわしいをソロ質問コーナーにしたいと思っており
ますので皆さんコメントの方
そしてチャンネル登録よろしくお願い致しますそして
えっ
その600万人記念の質問コーナーで
あの
ずうずう大発表というかちょっと飛んでもネオス出せをしようかなと思っております
おっとっとっと
これ以上言うとハードルが一番ねデッカーどうかわかんないですけど結構被っ
みたいな
きっと押せますがお知らせよする予定なのでぜひお楽しみに
はもなんかちょっと体張りすぎてここがすごい筋肉痛ですよってきて皆さんコメントを
お待ちしております
じゃあ
ゆるいな今日まあいいやああ
[音楽]
me
バッハ